il est il travaille à la ratp le jour il
est chanteur de rock la nuit didier
wampas revient avec un nouveau disque
les one pass vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas leurs noms mais il s'était
rendu célèbre avec l'une de leurs
chansons à propos de jacques chirac
christophe airaud mathieu dreujou
c'est l'histoire de didier chappedelaine
chaque matin il est dans les sous sols
du métro parisien
son job électricien mais le soir venu
ils et didier aux impasses le roi du
rock'n roll français
une vie souterraine celle de la ratp est
une ville musiciens sillonnant le monde
de séance m
une dizaine d'albums d'un punk potash
est allumé quelques tubes mais lui n'a
aucune envie de quitter le métro
je continue à vivre cette vie et être
libre dans ma musique parce que je veux
pas défendre les programmateurs radios
ou des maisons de disques pour vivre
dernière pochade dernière provoque le
groupe sim dans une grande maison de
disques et tout de suite se paye la tête
de leur nouvel employeur
non franchement la soupe c'est que c'est
une histoire vraie ce qu'il a vécu il ya
d'autres paroles mais quand on est
arrivé avec le disque nous ont dit c'est
bien mais ça passera jamais la radio
dont ils vont casser les pieds
réponse du patron pascal [ __ ] entrent
pleinement s'amuser et réalisme
économique
actrice universal tout à coup les
inspire tant mieux
après quel est le futur de wampas
universal ça dépendra de la hune
concours spector succès de leur vie et
de nous on verrait si leur dernier album
s'appelle l'est ou en pâte sont la
preuve que dieu existe c'est pas sûr
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
prouve que le rock'n roll et toujours
vivre